THROUGHOUT THIS HOUR WITH ALL OF
MY GUESTS.
BUT FIRST MY OPENING STATEMENT.
HE'S A LIAR, HE'S A LEAKER, AND
HE'S A LEFTIST LIBERAL.
IF ANYONE WAS NOT CONVINCED THE
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JIM COMEY'S
INVOLVEMENT IN THE ATTEMPTED
COUP FROM WITHIN OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT OF THE DULY ELECTED
WINNER OF THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, I HAVE JUST ONE
QUESTION FOR YOU.
ARE YOU STUPID?
LOOK, YOU DON'T HAVE TO BUY HIS
BOOK OR ARGUE WITH OUR LIBERAL
FRIEND ASSUMING YOU STILL HAVE
ANY LEFT.
JUST LISTEN UP.
COMEY'S BOOK TOUR WAS SUPPOSED
TO CONVINCE US HE IS AN
HONORABLE, LIKEABLE, DESCENT MAN
DOING HIS DARNEDEST TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
NATION.
COMEY WOULD HIT THE TRAIL, THE
BOOKSTORES AND THE TV STUDIOS
MAKING CLEAR WHEN HE WAS THE TOP
OF THE PERCH AT THE FBI, HE DID
EVERYTHING RIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR JIM, IT DIDN'T
QUITE WORK OUT AS PLANNED.
IN FACT THE MAN IS IN REAL LEGAL
JEOPARDY WITH HIS LEAKS BEING
INVESTIGATED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
NOT THAT I HAVE ANY FAITH IN
SESSIONS AND COMPANY THAT THEY
WILL EVER DO ANYTHING OF
CONSEQUENCE REGARDING THIS
FIASCO.
BUT LAST WEEK YOU REMEMBER I
TOLD YOU THERE WAS NOTHING,
ZILCH, ZERO, NADA IN COMEY'S
TWO-PAGE MEMO OF HIS MEETING
WITH THE PRESIDENT THAT IN ANY
WAY, SHAPE OR FORM THAT
INCRIMINATED PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THE PRESIDENT DENIED EVERYTHING
INVOLVING RUSSIA.
WANTED THE INVESTIGATION
VIGOROUSLY PURSUED AND HE WANTED
LEAKERS PROSECUTED.
SO WHAT DOES HE DO?
HE WALKS OUT AND LEAKS TO HIS
LAW SCHOOL PAL.
BUT HE'S NOT A LEAKER.
CHECK THIS ONE OUT.
BRET: BUT YOU DID LEAK MEMOS.
DID YOU -- IS IT OKAY FOR
SOMEBODY AT THE FBI TO LEAK AN
INTERNAL DOCUMENT FUN IT'S NOT
CLASSIFIED.
ISN'T THAT LEAK.
>> I DIDN'T LEAK MEMOS.
THE SUBSTANCE OF ONE
UNCLASSIFIED MEMO.
JUDGE JEANINE: JIM, YOU ARE NOT
A LEAKER.
YOU SAY YOU ASKED THE PRESIDENT
IF YOU COULD MEET WITH HIM
PRIVATELY TO DISCUSS A DOSSIER
BECAUSE IT'S PRIVATE AND YOU
DON'T WANT OTHERS TO HEAR AND
YOU DON'T KNOW CNN TO KNOW.
BUT ALMOST IMMEDIATELY AFTER YOU
DO CNN AND THE WORLD HAS IT, AND
YOU WANT US TO BELIEVE YOU
DIDN'T LEAK THE DOSSIER WHEN YOU
SAY IN THE MEMO THAT CLAPPER
TOLD TO YOU TELL THE PRESIDENT
ABOUT THE DOSSIER AND TELL HIM
IT WON'T BE LEAKED?
BRET: DID YOU OR OUR
SUBORDINATES LEAK THAT?
>> NO.
>> DOWNBRENNAN?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO LEAKED IT.
BRET: DID YOU TRY TO FIND OUT?
>> WHO LEAKED AN UNCLASSIFIED
PUBLIC MEMO?
NO.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU GIVE A MEMO
TO YOUR PAL DAN AND IT'S NOT A
LEAK?
AND YOU SAY, JIM, IT WASN'T
CLASSIFIED, BUT IT WAS MARKED
SECRET, WHICH IS CLASSIFIED.
THEN YOU SAY AS THE HEAD OF THE
FBI, I CAN DECLASSIFY.
YOU TOOK A DOCUMENT THAT WAS
WRITTEN CONTEMPORANEOUS WITH A
MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES ADVISING HIM
OF AN INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S A CRIME.
IT'S A CRIME TO CONVEY ANY
RECORD OF THE UNITED STATES OR
ANY DEPARTMENT OR AGENCY TO
ANOTHER PERSON.
AND YOUR FBI EMPLOYMENT
AGREEMENT BARS THE DISCLOSURE OF
FILES ELECTRONIC OR PAPER.
REMEMBER WHEN BARACK OBAMA HIRED
YOU YOU SIGNED YOU WILL NOT
REVEAL BY ANY MEANS ANY
INFORMATION ACQUIRED BY VIRTUE
OF MY OFFICIAL EMPLOYMENT TO ANY
UNAUTHORIZED RECIPIENT.
SO NOW MR. SLICK, YOU TELL US
YOUR FRIEND DAN RICHMOND IS A
SPECIAL GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE.
PRAY TELL, WHO MADE HIM THAT.
WHO DID HIS BACKGROUND CHECK?
LIKE McCABE AND LYNCH YOU JUST
THROW HIM UNDER THE BUS.
FEDERAL REGULATIONS REQUIRE AN
EMPLOYEE, EVEN HE, SHOULD NOT
ALLOW THE USE OF PRIVATE
INFORMATION TO FURTHER HIS OWN
INTERESTS.
AND HE HAD TO BE TRAINED AND
AGREE TO THIS.
HE HAD TO RECOGNIZE THIS
RESPONSIBILITIES REGARDING
UNAUTHORIZED DOCUMENTS.
YOU KNOW, JIM, YOU SAY IT'S NOT
A LEAK AND WE SHOULD BELIEVE IT
BECAUSE YOU SAID IT.
AND YOU ARE SO BRAZEN YOU THINK
YOU CAN CHANGE THE RULES A WE GO
ALONG AND WE'LL FOLLOW LIKE
FOOLS.
>> JIM COMEY HAS A DEFINITION OF
THE WORD LEAK THAT NO ONE ELSE
HAS.
WHAT HE SAYS IS A LEAK THE REST
OF US CALL A FELONY.
LEAK IS DISCLOSING A
CONFIDENTIAL CONVERSATION WHICH
IS EXACTLY WHAT HE DID.
JUDGE JEANINE: JIM, YOU LEAKED
THE MEMO BECAUSE YOU WERE AN
ANTI-TRUMPER WHO WANTED TO BEGIN
AN INTELLIGENCE INVESTIGATION
AND YOU WANTED TO EMBARRASS THE
PRESIDENT BY MAKING IT PUBLIC.
AND YOU DIDN'T GET THE REQUIRED
PERMISSION FROM THE FBI OR DOJ
TO DO IT.
AND JIM YOU AND I BOTH KNOW
SINCE IT WAS PART OF AN
INVESTIGATION IT BECOMES A 302
WHICH MEMOS CANNOT BE RELEASED.
MY FAVORITE PART IS WHEN YOU
SAID YOU WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT AND YOU REALIZED
THIS MEMO WOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO
GET A SPECIAL COUNSEL ASSIGNED.
YOU SAID IT REALLY WAS A
PERSONAL DIARY.
AS IF ANYONE AT THE FBI
ROUTINELY SENDS HIS OR HER DIARY
AS YOU DID TO THE CHIEF OF STAFF
AND THE FBI'S LEGAL COUNSEL.
YOU SAY THE GUY YOU ADMIRE MOST
OF IN GOVERNMENT IS GOOD OLD
JAMES CLAPPER.
THE GUY WHO DOESN'T LEAK OR
SURVEIL US WITTINGLY.
HE'S ANOTHER LIAR AND A LEAKER
WHO LIKE YOU HATES DONALD TRUMP.
THIS BOZO LIKE YOU FLATLY DENIED
LEAK THE DOSSIER.
HE EVEN RELEASED A STATEMENT TO
THE PUBLIC THAT HE ASSURED THE
INCOMING PRESIDENT THAT NEITHER
HE NOR ANYONE IN THE INTEL
COMMUNITY WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE LEAK.
AND HE DESCRIBED THE CORROSIVE
EFFECTS LEAKS HAVE ON OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
MEANWHILE, THIS WEASLE TOLD YOU
TO TELL THE PRESIDENT ABOUT THE
DOSSIER AT THE SAME TIME HE
APPEARS BEFORE A CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE FLATLY DENYING HE
LEAKED THE DOSSIER TO THE
COMMITTEE.
AND HE HAS THE CHUTZPAH TO
CRITICIZE PRESIDENT TRUMP?
ACCORDING TO THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE HE LATER HAD TO ADMIT
HE TOLD JAKE TAPPER, CNN, ON THE
ARE JOURNALISTS ABOUT THE
DOSSIER HIMSELF.
BEFORE TRUMP'S INAUGURATION, AND
NOW HE'S ON CNN'S PAYROLL.
AND TONIGHT, ISN'T THIS SWEET?
AS WE SPEAK, JAKE TAPPER AND
CLAPPER ARE GETTING AN AWARD AT
THE WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
DINNER FOR THE REPORT ABOUT THE
DOSSIER WHICH CLAPPER LIED TO
CONGRESS ABOUT AND SAID HE NEVER
LEAKED BUT WHICH WE KNOW HE
LEAKED TO CNN FOR WHICH
EVERYBODY IS GETTING AN AWARD.
JIM, YOU ARE PART OF AN
ANTI-TRUMP CONSPIRACY VIOLATING
THE FUNDAMENTAL RULES OF YOUR
OWN AGENCY.
DON'T THINK BECAUSE YOU WERE A
BIG SHOT AT THE FBI THAT YOU CAN
DISPEL THE RULES TO SUIT YOUR
OWN AND YOUR FAMILY'S OWN
POLITICAL AGENDA.
POWER, JIM, DON'TEER FORGET IT,
POWER IS RENTED.
AND YOU MY FRIEND HAVE BEEN